- Good morning, Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is pursue your passion.
Over to you, Kevin O'Leary.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- If you're passionate
and you're successful,
you'll wake up one day rich.
You won't really be going for the cash.
It'll just happen to you.
Everybody I talk to that's had success
doesn't remember the day
they became a millionaire,
no idea, not important to them.
They remember winning.
They remember building a
business and being successful.
Again, the pursuit of freedom
manifests itself in passion.
That's really what its about.
- So I just finished the
first chapter of my next book.
I'm super excited about it.
I'm basically taking the top 500 rules,
so I'm taking the top 50
people that you guys have
liked the best from my top 10 rules
times their 10 rules, we have 500 rules,
and condensing them down
to the most consistent,
most common top 10 rules
that everybody has some,
people who have accomplished
massive success.
And one of the ones that is consistent,
it's the number one rule is
around, following your passion,
doing the thing that you love.
And this is not something
new on my channel.
If you've watched Entspressos and Top 10s,
you've heard this message over
and over and over and over again.
- Passion.
- Follow my passion.
- Follow your passion.
- Recognize your passion.
- Passion.
- Passion
- Passionate.
- Passion.
- Why I'm really excited
about this one today
is because it's coming from Kevin O'Leary.
And Kevin O'Leary, you see
as the Shark on Shark Tank
and always talking about money,
and his goal is making money
and his goal is sending out his soldiers
to go out and make more
money and come back.
And his dream is to go
to bed a little richer
at night than he was
in the morning, right?
That's all he talks about on Shark Tank
and in most of his interviews,
and this one was different.
This one was talking about
pursuing your passion.
This one was talking about him saying
that most people don't
even remember the day
they became a millionaire
because they were
doing something much more important.
And I love hearing that message from him
because it's atypical from
what you normally hear
from Kevin O'Leary, but it's true.
The money's important.
Money's important for everybody.
Money is important for me.
I look at my budgets.
I look at my revenue.
I look my costs.
I look at what products are generating
sales and which ones aren't.
I look at, for this business, TDS.
I look at what classes
are generating revenue,
which ones aren't, how much we
can pay, how much we can charge.
I look at it constantly.
It's part of running a business.
If you are not making money,
you're going to go out of business.
The important thing though is there has
to be something more important than money.
Money is number two, might be number three
or four, but it's not number one.
If you are in business and
money is number one for you,
you're not going to have a lot of success.
There has to be something more important
that is passionately driving you forward,
whatever it is, no judgment.
It could be almost anything.
The thing that you would
do even if you weren't
getting paid to do, what is that?
For me, it's helping entrepreneurs.
I never thought I was going
to make money doing this.
And if you look at a lot of
successful entrepreneurs,
they have no idea how
they're going to make money.
You know, if you look
at Elon Musk, he thought
that there was a 90% chance
that his companies would fail.
But he just needed to go and try it.
When I started helping
entrepreneurs in doing speeches,
you know, three people
showed up to a free event.
Like, I'm never going to
make money off of this.
It's crazy.
Entrepreneurs don't have money.
How am I going to ever
turn this into a business?
I still needed to just
do it 'cause I loved it.
And even if it never became a business,
I would still do it because I have
the deep passion to helping entrepreneurs.
And by doing it over and
over and over and over again,
you start to maneuver, you
start to figure out ways.
Hey, I can monetize this.
This is how I can start
making money doing this.
Money's still important.
Money feeds everything.
Money allows me to hire a team.
Money allows me to grow bigger.
Money allows me to have a bigger impact.
But the number one goal for
me is helping entrepreneurs.
It's what fuels me.
I could spend all day
helping entrepreneurs
and not get tired enough
to go to the bathroom
and not have to eat because
it just fills me up so much.
I might crash afterwards, I
might be starving afterwards,
I might, you know, pass out afterwards,
but it's that insane drive
that pushes me forward,
so you need to find the
thing in your business.
It's the most important
lesson that comes up
consistently across
successful entrepreneurs
and athletes and musicians and actors,
and anybody who's reached
the top in their field.
You have to love what you're doing.
Pursue your passion.
And money's important,
but it's not number one.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious, what is your number one?
What's the most important thing
in your business besides money?
Super curious to find out.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I also want want to give a quick
shout-out to Mohammed Aftab Ali.
Mohammed, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
I really appreciate the support,
and I hope you enjoyed your read.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Everybody around me, their parents
were lawyers or investment bankers
or entrepreneurs, or
they were all involved
in business and that actually didn't seem
very much fun to me
growing up, so I thought
that being an adult's kind of a drag.
I actually was pretty depressed
when I graduated from college.
I mean, I was literally
depressed for six months.
I woke up at one o'clock in the afternoon
and laid on a couch and
looked up at the ceiling
and just said, "Dude,
what am I going to do?"
And so, with no
inspiration, I just decided,
you know what, the only thing
I can think of to do right now
that's going to make me
happy is if I go surfing.
And so I planned a five-month trip
around Australia and Indonesia,
living out of a backpack
and a van at the time.
If I didn't follow my passion for surfing,
I would have never had the idea for GoPro.
- Everything I did, I was following
something I really cared about,
something I loved, something
I was passionate about.
And I kept following that passion,
whether it was cars,
whether it was anthropology,
whether it was art, photography.
And eventually, it led
me to my huge passion,
my real passion, which was making movies,
which combined all of those things.
And I realized that had I gone on
to get my degree in anthropology,
I would have probably made
anthropological movies
in New Guinea or someplace
and eventually been
on National Geographic and,
you know, The History Channel,
and been then making features,
and I'd have done Star Wars just the same.
If I'd have gone in to Art
Center and become an illustrator,
I would have probably
started doing animation
and doing animated films
and making animated things,
and then ultimately, I would have
gone on and been right where I was.
So, no matter which route I took,
because I cared about all of them,
they all led to the same place.
Had I done what my father
had wished me to do,
which was to go into the office
equipment business with him,
which I knew I wasn't going
to to do, I knew I hated that,
my life would have been unpleasant.
So I think it's very
important not to do what your
peers think you should do,
not do what your parents
think you should do, or your teachers,
but to do what you inside, or even
your culture thinks, but
do what's inside you.
- Man, what happened to Pops
when he started a business?
He failed.
What happened to Mom and Dad?
They got a divorce.
What happened to us?
We have six different places.
Was it fun?
Hell no, it wasn't fun.
What happened in high school to you?
Did you play baseball?
Did you play high school basketball?
Did you get picked out for football?
Did you date the girl you liked?
What was your GPA?
Who were you in high school?
Who were you afterwards?
What makes you think you're
going to make it in life?
Man, you got to stop selling
this stuff to this guy, man.
Stop it!
It's getting old.
Go get that job that you let go of,
paying you 12 bucks an hour
and part-time get a degree.
Stop taking these damn risks.
We're not meant to do something big
with our lives, simple as that.
- Are we done?
- I'm done.
I'm good.
- Okay, good.
Pat, I want you to know, this
voice is never going away.
This voice is always going to be there.
No matter how much money
you're going to make,
it's always going to be there.
The great thing about it is, though,
every morning you wake up, you have
a choice on which voice to listen to.
But I want you to think about a
completely different thing right now.
Let's just say you do nothing.
Let's just say you buy into your fears.
Let's just say you buy into every
single thing you're worried about.
Let's just say you don't make any
decisions to go after your dreams.
Fast forward 10 years from
now, 20 years from now,
30 years from now, 40 years from now.
Let's just say your
funeral's around the corner.
You have 50 people
there, 100 people there.
Maybe 200 people show up.
These are your friends, family
and people that love you.
So you'll be loved for one generation,
remembered for two generations
and forgotten after that.
Is that truly the life you want to live?
Is that really what you want to do?
I don't know if that's the
life you really want to live.
You see, what I've noticed is,
no matter what you ever do,
you'll have a lot of lonely times.
You can lie to your family,
you can lie to your friends,
you can fool the world into realizing
that why you didn't win was because
of some challenge that you had to face,
but there is one person
you can never lie to,
and that is the man in the mirror.
You can never lie to the
man in the mirror, never.
For the rest of your
life, the man in mirror is
going to look back at you and say,
"You did not choose to
go after your dreams."
And you have to be okay with that.
Now, what I would like to encourage you
to do is to make the right choice.
I encourage you to face your
fears and pursue your dreams.
Go pursue the dreams that
matter the most to you.
You only got one shot at this thing here,
and if it works out, man, it's
going to feel so good for you.
And if it doesn't, at least you had
the courage to make that decision.
I hope you make the right choice.
I trust you will.